La I want to say thank you very much my
special recording at the dynasty
typewriter on Wednesday December 14th is
sold out I can't thank you all enough
for it we're gonna have a fun time uh
also here that they don't serve alcohol
so hey maybe you want a pregame y'all
I'll see you on the 14th
I want to make a very special
announcement here I'm excited to say
that
um
I have the crab Feast podcast back under
my control okay so uh it's every
artist's goal to get their you know
property back to them we got it all
right so
um
if you don't know about the crab Feast
um but a lot of you do I want to say
this I'm on the road meet and greets
people come up been rocking with you
since the feast man the feast the feast
the crab Feast is a podcast that I did
with Jay Larson it's a storytelling
podcast Audio Only
um we did it for about seven and a half
years there's 350 some episodes hell if
you if you listen to two a week it would
take you three and a half years to get
through it but it's a phenomenal library
that I'm very proud of
um it's what
um preceded the Honeydew for me and it's
got all the same favorite guests you
love sagora Bert Kreischer Bill Burr
Christina p uh you name it there's and
they're all different stories too so if
you love the Honeydew you gotta check
out the crab Feast
um subscribe to it today it's still
getting a ton of downloads already
there's an active community on Facebook
that goes through every episode uh and
it's been almost gone for four years
years now so
um feasters let them know uh honeydew
fans if you are looking for you're all
caught up on a honeydew and you're like
what else can I listen to I'm telling
you go listen to The Crab Feast it is a
fantastic fun uh storytelling podcast
you know there you'll get like man I got
this weird ghost story in a near death
and a marriage story into this where
that's what you know I the Honeydew for
me was the crab fees needed to have a
baby and I just focus on highlighting
the low lights here so go check it out
it's available everywhere you get
Podcast it's audio only like I said
subscribe
um join the fan pages have fun with it
I'm gonna be promoting it every week
here on the Honeydew now that it's uh
back in in control here so I'm very
excited about that thank you feasters
thank you honeydew fans enjoy the feast
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
like I always do every week thank every
single one of you for your support for
subscribing hit that subscribe if you're
watching Youtube just hit the damn
subscribe button it's a free way to help
the show all right and if you gotta have
more then you gotta check out the
patreon it's the Honeydew with y'all
where I highlight the low lights with
y'all and uh y'all have the wildest
[ __ ] stories I say it every week and
every week a new one pops up it's five
bucks a month there's no tears levels
we're not T-shirt cannon and [ __ ] it's
just five bucks all right if you sign up
for a year you get over a month free and
you're getting a honeydew a day earlier
getting it ad free and you're getting it
at no additional cost All Right tickets
for all uh tour dates are on my website
at Ryan dot com we got Chicago November
11th and 12th Grand Rapids December 9th
and the 10th all right that's the biz
there y'all you guys know what we're
doing over here we're highlighting the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers today
very excited to have this guest here
first time on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Rich Falls
welcome to the Honeydew Rich this is uh
this is too professional for me
all right this looks like it already on
that I go why am I here I'm at a place
our [ __ ] podcast we we tried patreon
and we lasted about six months ago we
can't do another one of these we can't
really can't do two of them uh we're
like every every like uh every every
week when you want to do it I don't know
I don't want to get up you know like
this is a studio you got a uh logo you
got [ __ ] cups and shirts it's just
it's let me tell you something if my
wife and I are not fighting on our
podcast then it's not a podcast you know
our best one is when I made her cry
anyhow well to promote that podcast it's
called My it's called my wife hates me
you know it's anywhere you can find a
podcast bus terminals uh you know
whatever my wife hey it's really funny
uh you know like I have my I'll tell you
tell them who your wife is in case they
don't know who Bonnie is oh Bonnie
McFarland yeah Bonnie's [ __ ]
hilarious he's on fire she's hilarious
she just sold like two TV shows she's
rewriting a movie she was an executive
producer on on a Netflix show in the uh
20 something you know her careers we
have the same manager
so he called me one day
and I go oh good something Good's
happening right and he calls me I go oh
I wonder what's up because he never
calls me he goes you have Bonnie's
banking information I I went I went from
a [ __ ] headliner to an assistant all
right I stink so you know uh you know I
got my I got my seventh album coming out
it's called Rich Walsh 7. I think it'll
come out two three weeks November and I
have a special that I shot a couple
years ago it's coming out it's gonna be
on like all these streaming platforms
like Pluto Roku but it's cool I shot it
at a 12-step convention I love that it
no one's ever done it it's so cool to
Bonnie directed the opening scene it's
so [ __ ] cool be it my my you know my
stage behind me looks like a 12-step
meeting has all the signs the coffee
pots Donuts chairs and uh no no
um Mick Betancourt do you remember mixer
Chicago guy he's a really good comedian
writer producer uh but he used to do a
show in the valley it was uh I can't
remember how many years running but it
was at an AAA because he was clean and
sober and it was at an AAA um Hall and
uh it was open to you know the what do
you call it patience I don't know you
know what I mean the patrons I don't
know the alcoholics and the users and
[ __ ] and it was the best [ __ ] show it
was so fun they those people have done
the wildest [ __ ] you could you couldn't
even imagine so hearing you talk about
your stuff and they didn't care if you
talked about drinking or drugs they're
like [ __ ] been there been there and
they were they you know you could go
dark and low on them because they've
been there it was so [ __ ] fun yeah
it's I've done a lot of conventions I've
done some with you know 2 000 people
uh uh I damn really two thousand
convinced big conventions you know uh a
cool thing I did I got a call they were
having a drug awareness
a concert next to the Washington
Monument when they call me to host it I
guess I got to the v's and uh
so they called me to host it right and I
uh
like I I hosted Woodstock 99 did you see
that documentary that's out I started
watching it I fell asleep I'm not gonna
lie I was on in the first 15 minutes
okay I'm going Let's Go Crazy let's go I
hosted that for three days not to there
was Tuesday side stage no the second
biggest it was East stage and West
anyhow so I've done some big outdoor
events but this one that's the one
everyone set everything on fire yeah but
that was the other stage they asked me
to come host that I said no way I'll
stay on my at my stage I sometimes had
50 70 000 people I had them all I had
about 70 000 people at the counter three
I go say hi to my daughters Jessica and
Ellen and I have it untaped all y'all hi
Jessica hi that's nice so uh
anyhow so I did this big event in DC
there was a uh probably fifteen thousand
uh and I got to do material I did like
five or ten a lot of people in recovery
it was just a drug awareness concert
Stephen Tyler Cheryl Crow
suspend The Fray and whatever it was
cool uh so I but you know also too my
career two weeks ago
I was working in Kenosha Wisconsin
and I wish it was a parade I was working
in Kenosha Wisconsin
so before I go on the the club owner
okay you're not going to do that many
f-bombs and I'm like oh anybody says
that that's still a thing
to me like first of all I know like my
seventh album is sparkling cleaners
because I want to get it on more uh
stations on Sirius so I mean I could be
cleaned whatever I could do whatever the
[ __ ] I want so
he goes no f-bombs or yeah but why
look he's an old guy he does a radio
show in Kenosha him and his wife it's he
introduces me oh uh this week we have
Rich for us two-time Oscar winner I
wrote on two Oscars if I won two Oscars
you think I'd be at your [ __ ] club at
the [ __ ] Holiday Inn in Kenosha you
[ __ ] jamoke all right [ __ ]
two-time Oscar winner look can we have
on our [ __ ] Fly by Night Radio Show
so that [ __ ] week
that Friday now he has two he has two
rooms at this hotel one gigantic
ballroom and then he has a nice size
that would be perfect
perfect so it wasn't it wasn't enough to
fill the big room and he lets people see
themselves right so it's a big opening
Horse Show in the middle so that week he
decides they're going to sell food at
the club he's gonna so as you walk in he
had all these samples but people didn't
see him as they walked in because they
would have samples here in the middle of
my show he has the waitresses passing
out samples I go I go is this what am I
working [ __ ] Costco what is this a
wedding
I right and I'm yelling at the racer
says stop
they're passing like people hey do you
want a little sample of pastry you fat
slob and uh
I lost it and f-bombs there was I I I I
forgot I forgot about that yeah like oh
really how am I not gonna curse when
you're passing out food like you know
and I I got off stage I yelled so like
you do some of these gigs they're great
I just called out the comedy club it was
up in uh Vancouver they got the which is
nice they give the terminal to each
table to pay their bill so that the
waitress isn't going back and forth
great but the [ __ ] thing beeps so
[ __ ] loud so you're just hearing beep
beep beep I I was I was like is someone
having a medical emergency
like for real are you okay and like I'm
just paying my bills like wait that's
something that the club guy was like of
course of course a comedy club would
give the fans something that would be
louder than their [ __ ] phone it's of
course they will oh no and there's
hundreds of them going on I you know I'm
doing it fireworks I'm doing at least
decent hour wherever I go 20 minutes are
dropping the [ __ ] checks 20. I go
listen you [ __ ] idiots you could sell
at least two more rounds and make your
money because that's your their job is
to sell wings and [ __ ] drinks that's
the difference between you and I love
doing clubs don't give me I love comedy
clubs you know I and I I like theaters
too but it's a whole different vibe you
know comedy club like sit on a stool and
I bring them you know what I mean and
and then when they're dropping you know
people like I'll be you know people are
on their phones and I'm like what the
[ __ ] they're trying to figure out the
bill you know so whatever it's a
business we're in all right well let me
ask you this question because we could
sit here and [ __ ] about comments I love
it I loved him too but you know so let
me ask you this you decide to do this in
uh at a rehab at an AAA you're St you're
special I'm talking about well no what
yeah it was at a at a what it was at a
convention okay at a convention
but did you pick that because you had
gone through this year like is that
something that really resonates with you
and is something you wanted to do to
help and no I don't want to help anybody
I
know I take me back to the beginning
first of all I got 36 years clean wow
congrats 36 years I did it for you and
this and this podcast yeah man thank you
not till he's 36 feet I said make sure
he comes ringed up too yeah
I'm a [ __ ] headliner [ __ ]
these are middle rings they're not
featuring no you can't imagine every now
and then I'll let a feature touch them
but here touch my ring let me tell you
so oh
I was
I was a [ __ ] drug I the night before
I went do you you know when I in the 80s
there was one nighters all over in
Jersey I'm from Jersey I lived
Connecticut New York I mean one night it
was like they were going you know I
would do one-nighters where I was
closing back then I wasn't a headliner
but I was the closer you know Chris Rock
would be in the middle Ray Romano and
you know Adam Sandler I'll tell you a
funny story with Adam me and Adam did a
a square a Holiday Inn in Scranton right
Adam and played guitars you know he he
went on and then I went on and after the
show the owner brought us in the back
and pulls out a big bag of Coke
and he says do you want Coke or money
and Adam took the money and I took the
Coke and you see where his career is and
you see where my career is okay but yeah
and so so
I knew I had to go to rehab I was going
on so I started smoking wait a second
let's go to the beginning you're from
Jersey you're how old now for real how
old am I yes like 65. it's amazing to me
I think you look great okay I'm married
I uh it's 65. yeah I think you look
great oh thanks
um
tell me about your upbringing and how
you get
drugs do you have older brothers what
did you were you cleaning sober up until
comedy started hitting you with those
one-nighters well what happened was
my gym teacher said too much teeth uh
no
you know as a kid
when you here's the deal and I don't
want to get too deep when you come from
a broken home like when I was young you
won't even know this I used to come home
from school in fourth grade and I would
listen to uh
uh this comedy album of Von meter every
day he did the impressions of the
Kennedys it's called The First Family
[ __ ] they got shot in his career was
done done this guy was the number one he
was a two-trick boy this guy was the
number one
had the number one selling album
like they said he went he went he went
from Park Avenue to park bench
he went he died and now a full-blown
alcohol uh and I used to come
what do you mean I think Lenny Bruce
walked on stage that night oh God I
think Lenny Bruce walked on stage after
the king I think he said well there goes
Von meters career right he was I think
that's the famous line he said uh so I
used to come home from school and listen
because and I didn't realize this till
later in life you know I'm covering the
pain in my parents divorce you know I'm
in fourth grade
are you an only child no I had a brother
who passed and my sister uh
my my sister's two years older okay
so it's so and
so growing up and my mom told his
brother when he passed
uh probably about
58 59 yeah am I still [ __ ] young and
the thing you know he diabetic he lost a
leg and still I'm paying full price for
a casket
all right I paid okay all right and
this funeral
the funeral
the funeral please don't mind me the
funeral
14 000 I'm paying you know I'm trying to
save money I'm like can we do three feet
you know what I mean look he did one of
his bits of [ __ ] bodak anyhow so
you grow up
doing negative [ __ ] negative attention
is better than none but you don't know
you know your mom's doing the best she's
working two jobs or one job and three
kids you know she's struggling like what
the [ __ ] she's a secretary you know uh
luckily we lived above my grandparents
for free they had a multi-family house
what age are you when your parents split
oh
fourth grade or eight nine eight or nine
uh
but I dress like a 12 year old uh sucks
eight or nine and and you live with Mom
and his dad so Dad would come yes or
would he around well no every like this
is how fun this is how [ __ ] up
parents are back then they didn't have
self-help and all that [ __ ] you know
you know I I remember like my dad would
come every couple two or three weeks and
we stand well daddy's coming you know
and then he come walking down the
driveway and detectives would jump out
of the bushes and arrest him
you witnessed that yeah yeah so we were
[ __ ] like we were they even know the
detective detectives
so that's good you were baked so we were
bait you know so who's more [ __ ] up
him for not paying child support or my
mom
I remember she we took the bus all the
way to New York from New Jersey to meet
him at the Port Authority detectives
more than once oh yeah not the same ones
yeah
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
unfortunately life doesn't come with the
user manual so when it's not working for
you it's normal to feel stuck therapists
are trained to help you figure out the
cause of challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills better help is
connected over three million people with
licensed therapists it's convenient and
accessible anywhere 100 online you guys
know I believe in therapy here
um you know everyone's out there working
out their bodies and we got to work out
those minds and those emotions and those
feelings so uh therapy is always a good
option alright as the world's largest
therapy service better help has matched
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with a therapist if things aren't clicky
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right there therapist
learn more and save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
Honeydew that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew if you didn't
already know 2022 has been one of the
most difficult times to try buying your
first home but great news 2023 is going
to be the year of the first time home
buyer with a recession buyers have more
power less cut through competition and
homes are about to get more affordable
so if you haven't listened to the how to
buy a home podcast now is the perfect
time since 2005 David has been the
Undisputed first-time homebuyer
Authority his how to buy a home podcast
has helped so many listeners close on
houses that they thought were impossible
David can guide you through the next
steps that are right for you whether
you're planning to buy a home now or
five years from now he can even connect
you with a great realtor in your town
that works with first-time home buyers
and actually cares about you plus he
just released a first time home buyer
starter kit and how to buyahome.com it's
a free resource with all the knowledge
you need to buy your first home start
planning this holiday season at how to
buyahome.com and make this the last year
you rent find how to buy a home on
YouTube and wherever you listen to
podcasts now let's
look to the do oh
but now like here like when my first
wife when I got divorced we're good
friends
because I did the opposite of my parents
with my kids
my mom did the best she could with the
tools she had
sir come on my chin yeah so uh so uh you
know you just learn you do the opposite
with your kids my kids grow up my kids
are [ __ ] great
so then you know but you give up a
little like me so then well you're doing
an extended family a little bit
grandparents
I was the black sheep okay our family
was the black sheep
like my cousins their family's dad
Hebrew School Scholars houses down the
shore and you know we're living free we
so we were
the black sheep
you know during all the big family
dinners at my grandparents you know
my mom was kind of the budgeted jokes
with like you know and I was the black
sheep of the black sheep family you got
it I was the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you know my cousins were all honor roll
students College I quit high school you
know I started a business did you really
yeah I started my own I had a good pain
I had a biggest paint in business in
town but I did Coke you know it's tough
and I was scared of heights so uh paint
my house I'll do the first floor you
don't see no this is true story it's on
my album It's stepladder and Below yeah
that is it this is uh it's a true story
i o drug deal everybody and everybody in
town money all drugs Everywhere I Go
every Friday I would paint I had an old
Dodge pickup truck I would paint it a
different color with house painting
there goes boss no he had a red truck
that's that's shutter green
one week it was brown I remember it was
right
and it wasn't even semi-gloss it was a
flat Brown Look at that yeah
so so
as you grow up doing doing negative fit
then you start hanging with
the same type of kids that come from
broken homes you you know I go up in the
neighborhood was
you know my back street
was all black people it was you know and
the front was like white people
so you grow up you fell I don't feel as
good as them or I don't feel like I
belong with them and I feel a little
better than I'm doing a little better
than the dudes behind me
so you actually hang out with
so you hang out and then it grows into
negative whatever it just escalates
what's your first drug ever a pot or no
alcohol me and Rudy drink his brother
Peewee gave us a bottle of Thunderbird
and we drank Thunderbird
[ __ ] maybe
okay and we we threw up the next me and
Rudy would you know Peewee and all the
dudes oh a lot of the dudes on my block
all died of AIDS from shooting dope is
that right back then and you know I knew
dudes they were all in prison or
shooting you know
these are just the dudes on my block and
I only hung with some of them the older
guys were you know
[ __ ] cars rip around the corner or
guns FBI or you know they're safe there
was my block was a lot of heroin deal
and heroin addicts and we were young
what area of Jersey Plainfield playing
field okay sudden you get older and you
progress and you start doing this drug
that drug and the next thing you know
you're smoking free base or crack we're
not that far
how old were you when you first did
cocaine and how did you do it you sniff
it
no it was on the tip of this guy's dick
I uh
so it was
it was you know I know a party with
friends I snorted you know we were
snorting
that early no it's probably after high
school we were doing like pot acid you
know going to concerts New York Dolls I
saw them on acid and
uh then 21
you know I get real bad anxiety I put
myself in a hospital they don't know
what anxiety is back then they really
don't they think you're just nuts and
they feed you with Thorazine and how you
know I'm doing a shuffle around every
day just shuffling around the [ __ ]
fifth floor of the [ __ ] psych ward I
remember my friends came to see me I go
we're going for our walk today I can't
have company you know oh so and I
haven't had anxiety my whole life
uh I get it now even talking when you
talk when I talk about myself deep like
this I get [ __ ] major anxiety
uh
so I I'm suffering from anxiety
then you just get older and you just
it progresses drug addiction
progresses with certain people if you
have that addictive personality
you're addicted to instant gratification
you know so
you know you're snorting coke you're
partying you're doing whatever
you're you're you're you're dealing and
then you're [ __ ] owing everybody
money because you're doing all the
product and it's just a [ __ ] night
moving from house to house painting that
[ __ ] truck yeah I mean you're just
fueling it that business is gone you
know okay at this point that's gone yeah
I hope
[ __ ] paint distributors thousands and
this is back then that's a lot of yeah
uh
it's a winning first Freebase how old
are you when you Freebase well I was
doing comedy I started comedy um
I was so bad at the beginning
so bad I didn't know I just want to be a
I I remember going to catch a rising
star a couple times I remember that
place in the hotel was it a no no not
the one in Princeton New York yeah the
real one and I remember seeing uh Lenny
Schultz she did props crazy Lenny I go
that's what I should do and I just went
to Toys R Us and pulled it and it was
just horrible
it's horrible
uh
I remember going on the first time oh my
God my friend's band was playing I went
on I just it was just so bad then I did
it
but then I started booking these rooms
one-nighters in where I would host then
other guys booking one-nighters like in
New York Connecticut
we would trade I'd say you could do my
gig and I do their gig so I'd get work
you know and I might one nighter I mean
I had [ __ ] top back I remember having
this headliner mulrooney
[ __ ] great
let me bought his own middle and the
middle Act
it's like I don't know if you know this
but I work at your Rising Star
uh I go well yeah you're making 60 bucks
a night and and it was it was Richard
[ __ ] Jenny oh he was opening for
marooni you know okay so I had all these
you know and I would get work and then
it built and built
but then there's two now I'm starting a
free base I don't know how are you
taking drugs instead of money also for
payment and things like no I'm just
taking the money and going to buy drugs
and does are you keeping this quiet is
this just a thing that you're doing no
I'm doing it with other Comics cremation
friends like you know I mean car
accident I mean just a complete
nightmare of drug addiction complete
Nightmare and it when you wake up is it
immediate like is it all day long no
when I wake up I'm like [ __ ] how am I
gonna get money to get high tonight
you know it's just horrible it's a
horrible feeling that next morning uh
I mean just nightmare stories after
nightmare car accidents stealing
whatever
you know probably the one of the lowest
things
it's a gross story but
I was in a bar in New York I had no
money left
I have 80 cents and I had 40 Cent drafts
I think I went in to have two drafts
and some girl comes up to me
she goes oh can I buy you a drink so I
go sit at our table
and she goes uh can I buy you drink oh
yeah so you got to go up and get it she
handed me twenty dollars and I walked up
to the bar and just ran out the door and
took it and went and bought two more
vials to cry you know so it's two years
or three years of just
here
[ __ ] drug addiction crack you got all
the way the crack well crack is Freebase
that's just a name
shall I did you ever put a needle in
your arm just only twice I didn't like
it you did though yeah twice it it
wasn't my type of high you know I didn't
like heroins you know so coke was your
yeah
so I remember one night I smoked an
eighth of coke about tuna and I'm ready
to [ __ ] so I go up to uh I got to go
to rehab so I go up to Fair Oaks
and I'm sitting in the waiting room I
had known I knew nothing
and by the time they saw me I came down
I said [ __ ] I left so there's probably
another half a year a year of running
and then
uh
I put myself in rehab I remember the
night before I was going to rehab
I call this Booker Gary Grant he booked
one-nighters
I said uh listen I'm going to rehab
tomorrow I need to get high can you and
he gave me this one night it was called
BF pakis or [ __ ] nightmare
I did it went to New York
bought five aisles of Coke
smoked them the next morning my mother
drove me to rehab and I have not picked
up a drug or drink a day since yeah I'm
trying to do the math in my head so if
you're 65 and you've been cleaning sober
36 around 29 you're going 28 yeah yeah
you're 21 clean and so yeah so
um
what's the closest to death you've come
in there and that could be
you know I remember one night we were
going to cop me and my friend and he
goes to steal
like a vial or two from these and they
pull out guns I go hey that was him not
me
yeah whoa you know you gotta do three
extra vials I had keys to front doors
and buildings up in Spanish Harlem
so I mean we were in car we were in a
car accident once where we took down the
[ __ ] light post 80 you know I should
have died there were you driving no and
we all got out it was just there's no
airbags or anything back then this was
Camaro I mean this thing was going
[ __ ] and we just spun all the wheels
are off the car I mean total
all of us should have died yeah and no
one did no one we all no and I went back
in later that night to New York
I I made three trips that night and the
next morning ended up in a hospital with
a kidney stone I didn't know what it was
and I think a couple weeks after that is
when I ended up in rehab but it was
close to death every time you're getting
high you're close to death you blow your
[ __ ] heart out you know
so you know and I say this all the time
too and I know I sound like an old white
guy but today if you don't get clean and
sober you're gonna die that fentanyl is
gonna get you it will get you sooner or
later you there's no way you could run
for three four years these days of
cocaine or whatever and not get a hot
shot I feel like the odds it's
impossible I mean we're getting high
every day smoking [ __ ] Coke that's
what I'm saying imagine sooner or later
you're gonna get one and I usually you
know once in a while snorted but like I
said it's like reading a book backwards
after you smoke it people go hey you
want some coke if we weren't smoking it
I didn't really want it you know that's
that much difference yeah so anyhow
uh I go to rehab they said you know you
can't do comedy for a year because today
I got a rehab I did a show that night I
got booked and I just haven't you know
my desire
to stay clean is much stronger I mean
right now I have enough money in life
I would die just watch I sell this watch
I'm dead you know what I mean I gotta I
didn't have any money there and I got a
family you would sell that watch for
back then is not what you would sell it
for today either you're gonna be pawning
that [ __ ] off for yeah yeah for a
hundred dollars well let's not get crazy
a hundred dollars I'll let you wear for
a day [ __ ] I'm wearing around
call you up where's my watch
time's up come on I'm on a [ __ ] watch
times
so and then
you know I started I remember in the
beginning like I mean I just I was
working for a guy once
and he was evicted out of his house
so he was staying at a hotel
uh
he had all his [ __ ] in this hotel room
so I get off stage and I said he doesn't
have my money
so I go in this hotel room I took his TV
they had still not the hotel TV and I go
home and my ex-wife is like what are you
working for a microwave next week you
know I have so many when you start
comedy I remember one time was the
scariest scariest scariest drug deal
transaction like
oh we're in New York I've never been
jumped all those times you've never been
jumped oh man
no I knew how to carry myself I you know
plus I was I was a good buyer they
didn't want to you know one time and
it's a true I mean I put this on maybe
back then it was different because I
feel like nowadays when you come down to
those neighborhoods now and they know a
white dude in these neighborhoods you're
you're gonna get your everything to
you're not getting your drugs your
money's gone and you might get out of
there
you know I uh one time was when the
somebody would go or with this another
drug addict he goes look I got a shotgun
let's go rip off some drug dealers and
we were this close we would have got
killed yeah because they had to look out
stamp there's no way we would and then I
said you know what this ain't gonna work
you know and we were at that point where
we were gonna that's how deep in the
addiction you are well you're
considering you're considering right
you're going well he's got a shotgun
you know we'll go
and but everywhere you go to buy those
places up in Spanish they got Lookouts
you can't you're not going in there with
a shotgun they all have so you just
crazy things in your head you know what
I mean uh one night I go oh maybe I'll
be a male prostitute and I sit on a
corner for about seven minutes and I go
and this ain't it's not my career
I just picked Any Corner I'm sure there
was a corner where they all hung but I
go I wouldn't even know what to do
I can just give me the money and I owe
you uh so I quit you know just stuff
goes through your head you're so high
but
you know it's but you're a one and done
rehab
yeah that's rare too oh it is I mean I
sit here on this show and listen to
people sit across me and they tell me
how they failed rehab time and time
again so to go once and then not a [ __ ]
up well because and I mean I think it's
one in 33 1 in 33 left something like
that
you know you're an outlier bro well it's
because
yeah what was
I didn't want to die or go to jail and
that's there was there's only three
endings
jail institution or death there's
there's no good ending you know and I I
talk to people I see people well I only
do it this day or that day or it's
whatever
and you can't
and this is all 12-step sayings but you
can't carry an attic you can carry the
message you know so your ego's not your
Amigo yeah there's so much that one
right there hits me hard well and
I only let my ego Drive in the car with
me now you know what I mean outside the
car we just shut the [ __ ] up he goes
easing god out
uh fear false evidence appearing real
there's so much to you and I'm not some
[ __ ]
12-step
uh zombie
you know I take what I want and leave
the rest behind or take what I need now
this Bonnie drink or anything like that
yeah she has drink yeah in front of you
too and are you okay and how is that for
you
she's not selling [ __ ] to get high
hahaha
that's the greatest
you know she uh you know she has one
drink she can't two drinks she's out she
has one drink and then never well my
question is it doesn't that doesn't
entice you to be like well let me have a
sip of that one or something like that
oh I mean listen I I'm an addict I
gamble and I play lotteries which I
gotta get in check I I mean I've always
gambled since fourth grade
let would you gamble one in fourth grade
we played roulette yeah and we pitched
quarters and you know whatever
I stopped going for 10 years and then
also I went back and it's you know uh
my problem is a lot of numbers I hear it
just
and like I was in the casino if I shoot
I step over a naked body and shoot craps
there's there's nothing more exciting
than shooting [ __ ] dice let me tell
you when that table's hot the head of
the clan is high-fiving Farrakhan
when the dice table's hot let me tell
you there's no feeling like a hot dice
table [ __ ] that get get Megan Fox away
from me I'm trying to [ __ ] hit a hard
eight so
but it's weird because
I've been to casinos recently where I
worked and I'm there for the whole week
and Monday night I win like 500. and I
don't gamble to rush a week I go I'll
leave with 500 or pay for my golf
you know but this time so I'm going you
know
hiding money in my room I don't bring my
credit card you know I'm back and forth
up and down so it's just addiction to
instant gratification yeah it's
addiction is drugs alcohol food stand up
all of it sound is just a symptom of
yourself right six all of it it's just a
symptom a symptom of
are you burying something are you
addicted to instant gratification or
look that's why stand up is so different
in acting because she's broadcasting too
I mean I get this with you now this
doesn't come out for a minute and you
know you forget sometimes what you even
talked about with people because we're
doing so many of these things we're
doing stand up every [ __ ] night every
weekend but that that good or bad you're
getting an instant [ __ ] hit yeah in
front of that you don't get that acting
people go to me you know your movie
might not come out for a [ __ ] year
yeah yeah it takes a long time to get a
movie out or anything yeah people go oh
you can't act it [ __ ] I'm a comic I'm
yeah I say telling a break surgeon you
can't do root canal I didn't study
acting [ __ ] do comedy anywhere I
could do comedy [ __ ] sleeping down my
couch wake up and do a set you know uh
and I can
semi Act
you know if especially if I get ad-lib
if you can ad-lib I'll [ __ ] knock the
scene out the box if I can just be me
yeah if I gotta be anything else I gotta
read lines I can't remember them I can't
read them anymore
so you know and I my comedy career
it's [ __ ] great I'm at the like I've
already won
you know what I mean I see you know
we're talking about all these Comics
doing crowd work on online
and this is an ego this is just bad
and besides me and I I've named this on
my new album I'm one of the best at
crowd work in this business hands down
but there's other good you know Big J uh
tell Bonnie's great Andrew Schultz is
great Rick Ingram is great yeah Jimmy
broken from back in the day was you know
there's a lot of good so but I did on my
new album my impression of bad crowd
work guy
okay and I like where you're from oh
I've been there I've been there you know
no jokes how long how long you're
married 11 years whoa almost 12. that's
what I do it
I close out my new album with bear
cowork eye but now you'll see on you
know
especially in New York a lot of these
they expect groundworkers they see so
much of it online
and I could do an hour I could do an
hour of complete crowd work believe me I
you know I've done it on second shows
where I'm going I don't feel like doing
material you know and you know and it's
not packed my [ __ ] career I bring my
own curtain the shows now
I stink I uh
Jesus
tis the season to indulge but if you
don't want to get so high you go to the
Moon let Dad grass help you chill out
and enjoy the ride their classic
pre-rolled joints hemp flower tinctures
and gummies are the perfect replacement
or pair to that glass of mulled wine or
third helping of pie that grass is legal
organic smokable hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind they're 100
organic pre-rolled joints and flour are
very low in THC and high CBD so you can
enjoy the effects of CBD while keeping a
clear head and now they offer a variety
of products so you can toke or dose just
the way you like from their CBD tincture
drops to the newly launched CBD gummies
and flavors like classic Blackberry
ginger good time hibiscus lime and
nighttime midnight Berry you can chill
out without getting stoned and dag grass
didn't forget your furry friends they
also released CBD dog bone so everyone
in the house can enjoy all dag grass
products are federally legal for ages 18
and over and it ships right to your door
anywhere in the U.S whether you're
looking for a new Buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite that grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood right now
dad grass is offering my listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
daggrass.com honeydew go to daggrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's daggrass.com honeydew this week
I've got Lamar Throne from more than 180
yards I got my homes rushing for more
than 40 and I got Aaron Rodgers throwing
for under 300 yards prize picks format
is simple and it's easy to understand so
even if you aren't a sports fanatic you
can still play and have fun pick two to
five players and if they will score more
or less than their prize picks
projection you can win up to 10 times
your money on any entry you're never
competing against other people it's just
you versus the projections available
there are projections for any sport you
watch NFL NBA MLB NHL PGA college
football college basketball soccer WNBA
Esports NASCAR Ted you name it it's all
there entries can be made in 60 seconds
or less they're safe and fast withdrawal
and it's currently operational in over
30 States and Canada download the prize
picks app or go to prize picks.com to
sign up and play daily fantasy sports
first time users can receive a 100
percent instant deposit match up to a
hundred dollars with your promo code
honeydew all right so if you deposit a
hundred dollars prize picks gonna give
you a hundred dollars if you deposit
fifty price picks gonna give you 50.
don't forget to enter promo code
honeydew at sign up for an instant
deposit match up to one hundred dollars
now
back to the do so
I want to ask you questions look I have
a daughter she's about to turn eight
um you have uh how many kids three three
daughters all daughters no Sons no okay
so you have a how old your oldest 32 all
right so 32 is from your first wife yes
my first two 31 30 yeah 32 and 30. so
were you
you had just got clean and sober then
for a few years right I think I had like
so they never saw Dad during addiction
never okay no and now your youngest is
how old 15. all right so [ __ ] great
as a dad of where you've been three
[ __ ] times yeah um I want to ask you
a question because we were just it's so
funny I just took my daughter we're from
I'm from Baltimore originally I went
back to visit my cousins in Ocean City
Maryland right and I was just down there
really yeah so we fly into Philly and we
got the two hour drive down to Ocean
City right and a good friend of mine had
come to see me that I've known since I
mean we're in sixth grade
and his daughter unfortunately got a hot
shot and she died from fentanyl so how
old 23 24. it's [ __ ] horrible
um so I'm talking to him and he's you
know he's emotional and everything and
my daughter sees it you can't hide that
so on the drive back to the airport she
asked me dad what was he crying about
what what happened to his daughter and I
was like
you know what you can either [ __ ]
her now or you can [ __ ] just straight
up be real with her and I chose to be
real and I was like I'm gonna tell you
what happened and I explained what drugs
are I told her what fentanyl is because
I I think there was a kid
it might have been the Middle School
here in Santa Monica where um some kid
took a Percocet from a parent's some
something a street perk and it killed
him it was hot so I told her about fence
why would a parent be fed well I don't
know I don't know if it really was at
the parents house I don't know where
they got it but they got him somewhere
and it killed this kid and it's all over
so I'm thinking you're you're going to
be there in two three years yeah so I
explained what fentanyl was I explained
drugs I explained what marijuana was and
alcohol and you know I I down talked the
whole scary marijuana [ __ ] I was like
listen of all the things out there
that's the one you know she knows I
smoke it she knows the neighbor smoke
and she knows everybody she goes sees
the stores the Billboards out here you
can't [ __ ] hide weed out here from
your kids so how did you
talk to your kids about it were you real
with them about it do they obviously now
sometimes I know your stories well I
took my my older daughters
they should go to meetings with me okay
because I had them in a day
so they you know they would play in uh
uh a kid's room or whatever
you know and they
both grew up with like asthma
so
you know they just knew I was an ex-drug
addict
and you know and you know they saw at
meetings that they never saw me high or
drunk so subconsciously they got to
think
you know he's a good dad
good life
he's not drinking or getting high so
something subconsciously you know my
kids grew up they drank they weren't you
know full-blown alcoholics
you know they partied they were [ __ ]
college kids yeah kids do yeah they're
college kids uh so I never had a well I
remember I have a video of my little
daughters
I was so cute they were
probably section four
it's on tape and I would I saw him on
the couch and I would ask him questions
I go
if a stranger pulls up to you what do
you do they go run run I go what if he
says he has a puppy run run you know and
there might have been some drug
questions you know and uh they're so
cute we run daddy run call the police
you know so
and and when my daughter now I mean
I leave it all up to Bonnie I bailed uh
so 15 years you've been out of the game
man you were almost out out huh yeah
well she oh God she's so funny and cute
and she just I mean she's beautiful
she's smart and I I try to tell her you
know because she's really I'll show you
a picture later uh
you know I always try to say
you're smart before you're beautiful
I always rather say you know I don't
want to I'm not sorry about all three
try I at least try to last first thing I
do too it's never pretty first ever I am
gonna battle that [ __ ] you need to
look good for a man or Society [ __ ]
[ __ ] be [ __ ] smart I wish I hung
out with the nerds in school yeah you
know I was a I was an athlete hung out
with the jocks these nerds are coding
[ __ ] and making billions of dollars
I don't have any of it
man be smart I I'm with you on that
because so so
you know she'll leave the house with
this Loca you got to change the shirt I
mean she doesn't but I tell her you
gotta you know
putting on makeup and you know I mean
she went from
you know a piece of plywood to like a
woman you know I'm like she's 15.
she hangs out with old friends and they
have sleepovers you know she has a good
network of friends or good girls
uh and by any other days like how come
she doesn't have a boyfriend here I
don't care you know did your other
daughters have boyfriend yeah God what
ages did they first have boyfriends that
you're aware of at least I think the
oldest was seven what no oh God damn
dude my daughter did tell me
no I don't know teenagers whatever
uh you know uh what's the first time
someone was brought home to meet you
well was it like a homecoming I don't
know my daughter's getting married she
called when she started dating this guy
she was scared to tell me like she goes
you know I'm dating this guy and he's
black
and right and Is that real though yeah
yeah I [ __ ] around somewhere yeah he's
light-skinned he uh you know so but she
thought I was gonna be mad I grew up in
all
and all
diverse neighborhood
you know I mean I've done every Urban TV
show I go why would I be mad about that
if he's good he's good to you a good
person you know I don't care the white
dude you went out with are [ __ ]
assets exactly I go those guys were ass
[ __ ] white garbage yeah they were
gone that one dude you know I mean one
was cool her boyfriend before that was
cool he was a good golfer he was cool
and the one before him was a [ __ ] up I
mean a complete [ __ ] up so I don't care
I mean you know my other daughter who
married this guy you know way to his
wife as white as white can be you know
red hat white uh you know [ __ ]
ugh he's just he went to like some ivy
league College
you know I'm like Ugh you're just just a
perfect jaw you know he's a [ __ ] Jaws
white it's like a a jaw a white dog
it's like the kind of jaw that rejects
[ __ ] minorities for for a [ __ ] car
loan
we don't have a shot
you know I just started that
oh
you just wanna
punch him in his [ __ ] waspy [ __ ]
bankers
so
and the other dude is cool
he plays ball you know
talk Jordan sneakers you know
uh you know and as long my daughters my
the one who's getting married
she has a townhouse and a real nice
[ __ ] area in Jersey they bought a
house in Tampa where they Airbnb it to
get ready to buy another house this
kid's 32 she's gonna have three [ __ ]
houses you know what I mean yeah you're
doing well my other daughter lives in
she bought a [ __ ]
a 750 000 house earner earner [ __ ]
job husband all right had a bait just
had a baby you know and these are my you
know I was [ __ ] this is all too
you know from telling jokes right from
going on stage you know uh
you know I got to do a speech at my
daughter's wedding you know in two weeks
I I just I I just can't offend anybody I
know how I am you know because there's
going to be a mixed audience you know
and I'll start doing crowd work you know
and oh my god
well my daughter's first wedding right
the night before at the rehearsal dinner
his father gave a speech you know he
came with slides of them you know
together growing up he had a whole
[ __ ] presentation
so I didn't I just went up at my
daughter's wedding I go first of all I'm
not like this [ __ ] boat act all right
I didn't prepare I call him the boat act
or whatever I don't know I go get him in
his dumb slides I'm sure I'm surprised
he didn't do magic right I'm just
trashing him and I moved on but then
I'll write some bullet points but it
comes from here just like comedy to me
look there's great comics
but to me good comedy comes from the
heart not the head like you well it
starts with the heart and you polish it
with the head yeah no but there's joke
tellers yeah when you leave a show for
me um like I love all comedy don't get
me wrong my favorite you know I love
Maria Bamford I love [ __ ] stano you
know I love Ultima Reagan you know from
up and down but
when you leave a show to me I'd rather
know something about that person you
know you could leave someone show and go
what'd they say I don't know but it was
funny right but you live a show and go
wow
what a life you know what I mean you
know you uh
so
you know it's all different and like
someone like Maria Bamford you just know
she's very she's out of her [ __ ] mind
she's so good you know and same with
Stanhope too he'll take a bit and go
uh you know in complete circle and he go
holy [ __ ] he does a bit
about uh a third world guy going to a
[ __ ] American prison it's as funny as
anything I've ever heard anything I've
ever it's so funny in your thing or
Patrice when me and Patricia me and
Patricia were good friends we'd hang out
and when you made him laugh it was
so
electrifying when you said something and
there was no better feeling than me I
made Patrice laugh when he fell on the
ground
you know it's so electoral and he's made
me you know me and Patricia were walking
down the street when I was giving him a
ride home
and
uh he just said me and Patrice were
walking down the street one night I was
giving him oh No I gave him a ride okay
and then we're walking down to his you
know we get walking to his house
and he looks at me and goes I don't have
a [ __ ] thing going on in my career
nothing I go I don't have an agent a
manager nothing and we just both started
cracking up laughing like you know we we
didn't audition me and him
for
the two leads in a sitcom
so we're auditioning for Marcy Phillips
to head of casting for ABC nicest lady
in the world
and we're up there
and I can't act and he doesn't want to
be there so he won't take his face out
of the copy
and we're trying and she's yelling at me
I go how the [ __ ] can I connect with a
guy that won't look at me
and we're I'm trashing him he's going
[ __ ] you and this and then she goes can
you two just leave wow really and we
just walked down a hallway
laughing we just blew any and we we just
started laughing it's so funny to us
and we're walking down the hallway and
there's three Executives behind us
and I didn't mean to but I farted
and he fell underground laughing so hard
because the executives were all [ __ ]
like oh uh you know there's certain
Comics like that that'll laugh like when
you do when I do radio with Gervais
Ricky his laugh is so electrifying yeah
he loves Comics yeah he's one of my
favorites he'll laugh like if you say
something funny like there's no ego and
you could trash them too you could you
know he's gonna trash you you he's just
like hanging with the dudes and that's
how our crew was in New York we were
[ __ ] brutal me Patrice Norton uh
Keith Robinson Bobby Kelly you know
Kevin Hart started with our crew Bill
Burr we were all [ __ ] ruthless we'd
beat Billy down one night at the sheller
so bad he came in
he came in on and we're all sitting
there and he goes I'm going to the World
Series the Yankees were playing the Mets
he goes I'm going to a World Series and
we're like how do you get tickets she
goes I'm doing a show on these guys
hired me to do a show on their bus
to the game and for 45 minutes we
[ __ ] did sweat was pouring down his
face
trees we did like we were doing stuff
like you guys were a good crowd
walking off the bus and particularly
like once she said that like our eyes
lit up because we go here's oh my God
[ __ ] victim yeah victim uh
and we had so much fun and then Patrice
you know one night the closest week came
to I mean Kevin I walked in one night
with a little bump on my lip and
everybody's yelling Voss has herpes and
they're yelling it in top of the cell
everybody's saying they're packing at a
table for us has herpes you know [ __ ]
done with little Kevin Hart with his
little hands bouncing on the [ __ ]
table you know boss has herpes and now
he's not you know uh
the closest we came one night we were
sitting in the cellar
who's the nicest guy in the world
Russell Peters walks in he's done the
show yeah and he he has this
you know what a peacoat is you know the
navy color but he has one up to his
waist okay he's walking in with his crew
and we look at his coat
and we just me Keith and it's just
non-stop and Bonnie goes you look like
the little boy on Boardwalk Empire
and we just like so nobody with his crew
would laugh but we were he came in the
next night [ __ ] just firing off [ __ ]
at us he came in he goes [ __ ] these guys
and and the nicest guy in the world so
we had like our table in the back of the
cellar
you know it was in the doctor Patrice
doc they talk about it we were
[ __ ] Ruth but it was fun we were so
funny we were like just Comics having
fun then we leave there and a lot of
nights would be me Patrice Keith
Robinson and Jim Norton would stand in
front of Boston comedy club and just
trash each other
until three or four in the morning and
it was the most fun and the best times
in comedy you could have like now we
were I was sitting at the table and
there was some young kid he said
something and I trashed him and he went
what's that about like what what's that
about shut the [ __ ] up it's attraction
you dummy you know they're so
thin-skinned and so you know and I don't
think La is like New York I don't people
don't shoot around
we grew up hey [ __ ] was just a polite
way to get someone's attention you know
what I mean yeah it was never it was all
ball buster it was all who just I want
to make you cry like you want to make
you cry yeah and then he's like I'm
sorry
it's so funny if I'm [ __ ] with you
that means I like you yes amazing time
on you right now so many MC's on the
road you know I'll go do you have my
number at the end of the week and they
go no and I go good and walk away
you see me in New York don't act like
you know me right
I'll act like we're buddies all right
also I'm not an [ __ ] like if so many
of them can I sell merch and I always
say yes I'm not one of these headlines
you can't of course they don't make any
[ __ ] money you know so
it was so much fun
throughout the career now it's this is
what I want to ask you a question how
many years in comedy were you using how
many years were you doing comedy just
three years three years two or three
three years how long do you think
you could have kept that up
while in comedy I would have died you
would have died I would have got shot or
call action or watching a shot just from
I would have got myself in a position
somewhere trying to rip somebody off or
did like I was
I was working in uh Boston I met a
this one outside a waitress
beautiful
I know I go can you get Coke up here we
drove from Boston to New York I spent
all my money we got a hotel room to Coke
all night
and she said my sister wants an ounce of
coke can you get in here
and I would have ripped her off in my
head just I would have ripped her off
easily
three years later I'm working in Florida
and that sister's in the audience with
her monster boyfriend nah so if I would
have ripped her off you know she I mean
and she came up to you and told you I'm
the I don't know she goes oh yeah you
met my whatever
um
so nothing good would have happened if I
would have kept doing it it's not like
you know oh I'm a crack at a hitting
Lottery you see there's no good ending
yeah you're right there's no good
there's no good ending there's no you
don't [ __ ] get a trophy you know uh
institution or incarceration there's one
of those three so
luckily
I stop when I stop because the
progression was out of control
and thank God I didn't wasn't making
money doing comedy you know I would go
on the road
and MC for 125 for the week it probably
cost me 50 to fly there yeah I would go
let me ask you this you battle addiction
so you've beat the alcohol drug
substance you've beat something somebody
say you gambling's uh here and there
it's an issue yeah what do you do to
[ __ ] Center yourself to really
actually check yourself
uh what do you mean by like I mean like
if you're ever I think that maybe you're
doing too much gambling or whatever like
you obviously you have a an ability to
reset yourself or self-check like what
do you do does it just hit a point where
you finally go hey enough of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] or well you know I mean you
don't look like you meditate maybe you
do no I don't know okay all right all
right [ __ ] Gandhi I uh like
meditate shut your mouth I I know my
wife like I got 30 36 years clean and
meditation is a big
I don't meditate I don't know how and I
I'll go buy the my wife's room and she's
meditating and and I I'm jealous that my
wife you know her career is taken off
she tries to she had the best analogy
you know she goes you know think she
goes because I have a a lot of times my
power thinking things happen for me when
I do it it's for some reason she was
just think she goes if you want to be a
millionaire
you'll be one right
and then I said to her
uh God gives you what you need not what
you want
she said do you think Chelsea Handler
really needed a TV show
yeah
uh I do got to start meditating I do I
think
four hours
I I'm as disconnected with this are you
gambling on the game though no once in a
while me and my friends will play five
dollars but I usually I go
by myself and they put me with three
people or whatever and they asked me
what I do for a living I tell them an
FBI profiler then I just [ __ ] my way
through that you know or whatever
because I read a couple John Douglas
books back when I used to read someone
new everything
you know back in the day so uh I guess
getting
away is playing golf or when I'm doing
yard work I had my for three years I
ended season three of landscaping with
Rich which I didn't
what dude I had this idea for a show
years ago I was trying to pitch where
it's called I'll cut your grass yeah
because I'd be on the road meeting
people to meet and greet they're like
well it's so cool what you do it's so
cool I'm like what are you doing like
nah tomorrow I'm just cutting the grass
I'm like do you know how much I would
love tomorrow to just go [ __ ] get on
a riding mower and cut the [ __ ] grass
oh and I wanted to do a give back show
where
um you know maybe it's a woman who has
breast cancer and she has to go get her
chemo and you know the house is a single
mom in the yard I'm gonna come cut your
grass
come touch your grass that's a good you
know what I mean you go you're single
dad and you haven't been with the kids
or whatever it is go take your kids out
and have a good time I'll cut your grass
see that's funny I did three seasons of
landscaping and Rich but if you look it
up I would say what I'm gonna do okay
Tim
gonna put in you know uh
40 armor bodies
and then you know I say hey welcome to
Landscaping Ridge and this is today's
project you're gonna be with me all
along the way we're going to get this
done together
and and then I would just show at the
end to finish product I wouldn't show
them me doing anything it would just be
a picture of the arborvotti's [ __ ]
planted so I never did anything but I
always set it up when I was doing it but
all the deer in my neighborhood I have
an acre of property
I planted 18 36 Arbor bodies or the deer
ate them they all they're sickly
so then in the front I took them out and
put
in the front 20 I'll I put big rocks out
front of my house you know how they
later then I put between them uh 20
Alberta spruce
and we had a drought and a heat wave and
they're all dead they're brown dead and
I ended season three I go listen it was
a great season but everything's dead
it's a wrap it's a wrap I'll see you
next year all right look first of all
thank you for coming on here and talking
about this I don't know how I got into
the whole us and our crew and Patrice I
always end up talking about that because
that was my favorite time in the
business you know and we're in a tough
business yeah we are and and yeah that's
the moments that matter yeah I love
doing I love doing stand up I love
creating
you know and
if
I was getting high
I wouldn't have any I wouldn't have my
family I wouldn't have
comedy
I wouldn't get a free [ __ ] rhyme
schickler mug yeah man you don't know
this I'm gonna use it tonight I can't
wait uh and so I I go off in tangents
and I'm sorry if I did no yeah that's
your episode dude yeah uh this is what I
want to ask you though I told you at the
beginning off my let's start over
I was gonna ask you
uh advice you would give to your 16 year
old self and it's interesting because
that's you a couple years into just
drinking maybe and doing some smoking
some pot you know it's about to come
your way in a few years what advice
would you tell yourself
try not to come so fast
I'll leave [ __ ]
I don't know uh
I bet you no I bet you nine out of ten
people go
Buy Apple buy Microsoft no they really
don't they after an episode like this
they they really do look back
to myself [ __ ] around cocaine but no I
would probably say uh
be more grateful enjoy what you have in
life
I go you know don't compare identify
and just be more grateful that's great
advice don't compare identifying I'm on
this gratitude thing right now big time
too good we're in a business where
you're like what the [ __ ] you know
and also at the end of the day none of
this [ __ ] matters listen you got your
family you got your health none of this
stuff my grandkids you got a son-in-law
you don't like but whatever he's got a
great job no but it's true I've been in
a business and I have a minor speech
impediment my shs I [ __ ] made a
career out of talking
yeah you know yeah and I I followed
Chris Spencer last night I had no
problem
he killed uh yeah just have
I have more gratitude be grateful
um plug and promote everything again
please
uh
our podcast is uh my wife hates me it's
where everybody you know podcasts are
played uh
my album Rich Voss seven should be out
two or three weeks four weeks on iTunes
or whatever
special uh
uh Rich voice anonymous
will be on in November it's coming out
on all streaming
you know like Pluto Roku all that [ __ ]
uh my manager's coming out with a whole
new streaming uh
I don't even understand this uh uh
I forget the name of it anyhow uh it's
gonna be everywhere and you know what I
don't know whatever I'm not a just if
you uh
look here's my advice
if you're at a podcast and there's a
different candy
take something hello
get some candy
dude thank you for coming on for real so
thanks for having me um as always Ryan
sickler on all social media Ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week
foreign